[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vagabond quitte la bretagne le 12 mai
2002 cap au nord eric brossier son
capitaine et france pinczon du sel
navigatrice se sont rencontrés sur les
chemins de laventure tous deux
passionnés par le grand nord et la mer
il partage aujourd'hui leur vie à bord
de vagabond voilier polaire spécialement
conçu pour la navigation dans les glaces
fasciné par les régions sauvages et
glacées de l'arctique
il prépare depuis plus de trois ans une
expédition con qu'un voilier n'a réussi
à ce jour
relier l'atlantique au pacifique en
longeant les côtes russes en un seul été
et sans l'aide d'un brise-glace cette
voie maritime est totalement bloquée par
la banquise pendant l'hiver la courte
période de l'été arctique ne laissent
souvent qu'un étroit et dangereux
passage entre les plaques de glace long
ou de près de 7000 kilomètres c'est
route fut convoité pendant des siècles
par les européens
elle leur aurait permis de faire du
commerce avec l'asie sans passer par les
mers du sud contrôlées par les espagnols
ni par l'intérieur des terres contrôlées
par les turcs
mais au cours des différentes tentatives
de passage par le nord des dizaines de
bateaux sombrèrent broyé par les glaces
et des centaines de marins périr du
froid de la faim et du scorbut
cette voie maritime est ainsi devenu un
mythe pour les navigateurs et fut
baptisé passage du nord-est
deux équipiers accompagne eric et france
pour cette expédition gérard guérin
aventuriers au long cou aux passionnés
par les régions polaires et karen mulder
une hollandaise qui étudie les peuples
du nord depuis un mois vagabond remonte
la côte norvégienne pour atteindre le
port de mourmansk en russie cette
première escale sera déterminante pour
l'expédition les autorisations du
gouvernement russe nécessaire pour
naviguer le long des côtes de sibérie
sont très difficiles à obtenir
nous ne savons toujours pas si nous
pourrons nous lancer dans cette aventure
rêver et préparé depuis plusieurs années
la plus grande appréhension je pense que
c'est quand même le verdict final les
autorités qui peut on le sait très bien
être négativement donc
poser les doigts on peut pas non plus
changer la politique ressemble
après avoir passé le cercle polaire les
franchit le cap nord nous voici en mer
de barents à mourmansk la porte d'entrée
du passage du nord-est
[Musique]
mourmansk quatre cent mille habitants la
plus grande ville de l'arctique c'est un
port de pêche qui a longtemps alimenté
en poissons les villes de russie et un
port militaire qui abrite une grande
partie de la flotte russe sous marin
brise-glace navires militaires cargo et
chalutiers s'y côtoient c'est ici que
navires marchands est en guerre se
réunissent pour former des convois avant
de s'engager dans le passage du nord-est
escorté par un brise glace ce chemin est
de loin le plus court depuis l'europe
pour atteindre le pacifique mais sa
fréquentation a cessé peu à peu depuis
la fin de l'époque soviétique
il donne et enjoignait de chez noir de
chagas post 1 tu as des indes au chan
yung l'achat après quinze jours d'escale
sans réussir à obtenir les autorisations
erin décide de se rendre à moscou dans
l'espoir d' activer le processus auprès
des ministères concernés
l'équipage rester à bon s'affairent aux
derniers préparatifs vagabonde doit être
prêt à toute éventualité car restés
bloqués tout un hiver par la glace est
une situation visage et à ce jour tous
les voiliers qui ont emprunté cette
route ont subi ce sort
la réussite de cette expédition dépendra
beaucoup de la bonne préparation du
navire gérard est le mécanicien du bord
il a vécu chez les inuits du canada en
laponie et au groënland
ces expériences arctique l'ont amené à
conduire un attelage de chiens de
traîneaux et à vivre dans des conditions
extrêmes auprès des peuples du nord
comme on a des risques de
de passer un hiver je voulais être
complètement autonome au niveau
réparation s'il nous arrive quelque
chose
j'avais envie qu'on soit capable de
réparer tout ça quoi donc j'en ai un
poste de soudure une meule des outils à
boursies circulaire si sauteuse mais bon
réparer une petite avarie évidemment si
si si un iceberg qui rentre et qui perd
sa coque
pour une bricole les merdes pour aller
informe et papa tout réparer mais joe
l'essentiel quand les petites choses
france travaille depuis plusieurs mois à
la préparation des vivres du bord les
aléas d'une telle aventure nous oblige à
instaurer un rationnement journaliers
pour garder une autonomie maximale pour
6 personnes et un nom il ya 100 armes de
féculents par jour 100 g
alors ça fait ça lui convient ça fait
200 kg féculents 200 kg de céréales 100
kg chocolat 100 kg de cacahuètes que des
chiffres un peu comme il est comme ça et
c'est des trucs qui vont qui font comme
des repas survie de base à prendre
agrémentent si on pêche temps viendra
des poissons les résultats on a vraiment
de quoi tenir pendant un an
voilà ce qu'on avait oublié les choux
fleurs et je crois que c'est ce qu'on
servait bienvenus apparemment porte
karen a déjà vécu en russie et en
connaît les difficultés
sa maîtrise de la langue russe fait
d'elle l'interprète de l'équipe et nous
permet de communiquer avec les autorités
et la presse locale intrigué par ce
voilier et son étrange destination
peter sagan
[Musique]
jno des beaux gadins et ça va venir sa
fille mon ami alors que les démarches
auprès des administrations russe se
prolonge un autre voilier étrangers est
arrivé aux côtés de vagabond d'aghmat à
n-1 vieux gréements il attend lui aussi
le feu vert pour se lancer dans
l'aventuré du passage du nord-est son
capitaine harvey touche là déjà tenté
sans succès à trois reprises nous sommes
donc deux voiliers à relever le défi
cette année d'aghmat n ayant obtenu les
autorisations plus rapidement que nous
prend quelques jours d'avancé
la tante nous semble interminable
pourtant éric de retour de moscou
finalisent les dernières formalités
c'est seulement le 30 juillet après six
semaines d'obstination et de patience
que vagabond et son équipage sont enfin
autorisés à reprendre la mer
cette autorisation ne vous donne pas le
droit de faire des recherches dans
l'arctique russe fait deux péchés ou de
faire du tourisme
tout le temps que vous passerez le nom
de la route maritime du nord gary morse
connais pas qui nous lie à dire c'est
une salle pleine ministre à jean
fernandez ne va pas criaient à bas c'est
un n'diaye n'guemo hadji jeannot bakar
pas les 10
par diplomatie et pour obtenir les
autorisations nous avons accepté un
nouvel équipier boris revenir c'est un
navigateur russe qui a passé une partie
de sa carrière à convenir des capots et
des tanks air sur la route du nord face
et de menus mme cinq maires à franchir
de l'autre côté le détroit de béring et
l'océan pacifique
c'est un objectif qui nous paraît bien
lointain si nous l'atteignons cette
année cela symbolisera une victoire dans
l'histoire de la navigation polaire
nos chances de réussite dépendront de
l'état de banquise
si les glaces reste trop dense
nous y verrons comme l'ont fait tous nos
prédécesseurs
notre destin est maintenant lié aux
conditions climatiques
sur cette route on sait qu'il ya de la
glace à gauche en gros au nord est de la
terre à droite et bon ben il faudrait
pas qu'ils aient un coup de vent de nord
est qui ne coince ne croise un petit peu
fort contre la côte
ensuite c'est plutôt au niveau de la
résistance physique que de quelques
inquiétudes c'est vrai que s'il ya des
glaces lourde pendant longtemps il
faudra s'organiser en conséquence
c'est-à-dire dormir deux heures tous les
quatre heures
eric france et gérard se partagent les
cards veille quatre heures de jeu et
quatre heures de nuit chacun ils sont
alors seul responsable de la navigation
et surveille la présence de glace
jour permanent de l'été arctique
permet de surveiller
et plus facilement les glaces
[Musique]
conçu spécialement pour les régions
r il a déjà beaucoup navigué dans
l'arctique sa coque renforcée c'est
élise protéger et son étrave incliné le
rendent plus efficaces pour naviguer
dans les glaces un poste de pilotage
avancés avec une grande surface vitrée
permet au barreur de rester à
l'intérieur
aidés des conseils de la vigie installé
en haut du mât ce poste d'observation
permet de trouver le meilleur itinéraire
lorsque des plaques de glace entre danse
[Musique]
les cartes de concentration de glace que
nous
d'abord par liaison satellite nous
montrait le détroit de kara totalement
bloqué passé ce détroit
la mère libre de glace nous permettent
une progression rapide jusqu'à dixon la
première de nous trois escales autorisée
c'est ici que nous rejoignons le voilier
allemand dagmara m c'est un vrai virus
président soviétique
j'ai lu et de gens moi on m'a dit que
dixence un petit désolé mais c'est
vraiment désolé il n'y a pas beaucoup de
gens qui restent ici et tout c'est noir
il ya beaucoup de charbon là bas et tout
se passe avec le vent ici elles toutes
les villes et noir et tout est cassé
mais des gens ils sont vraiment
sympathiques
nous rencontrons des enfants d'une
classe russes venus à dixon pour visiter
une station polaire
karen leur montre la timonerie et le
carré d'habitation ça c'est la barre ça
c'est le radar est ça le gps vous
connaissez le gps il nous donne notre
position
là c'est l'ordinateur avec toutes les
cartes maritimes et là nous avons la
liaison satellite pour connaître entre
autres la météo ou l'état des glaces
après dixon la prochaine étape sera
tiksi mais nous ne savons pas si nous y
serons dans une semaine dans un an après
un hivernage dans les glaces
par sécurité karen qui a des problèmes
de santé préfèrent débarqué ici
boris sera désormais notre seul
traducteur à bord nous avons effectué le
premier tiers du trajet en un temps
record mais il nous reste encore cinq
mille kilomètres à parcourir
si nous voulons garder toutes nos
chances d'atteindre le détroit de béring
cette année il nous faut partir
rapidement car les mouvements de glace
sont imprévisibles
nous partons quelques heures avant le
voilier allemand dalmat rennes
direction le cap chelios quine le point
le plus au nord de tous les continents
un des passages les plus difficiles de
cette route maritime
je
et
nous essayons de rester en contact radio
avec les allemands afin de nous échanger
les informations de glace et de météo
mais aussi pour connaître leur position
je vois pas de quatre mois et d'ici je
vois la poissonnerie du parti
d'opposition
[Musique]
photo en plein soleil on note dans les
airs littorail sedan les ali talât
island and fog wiiware planning to
shatter faro east en longue de coast
highway a frôlé waiting for you to go
away waiting for good
[Musique]
à plusieurs reprises nous devons
utiliser les perche à glace pour
continuer à progresser
elles servent à repousser les morceaux
de banquise et est à se frayer un
passage lorsque les blocs de glace sans
trop dense pour naviguer librement
[Musique]
dans la tête des petits blocs
tu peux faire ça mais c'est pas des
petits blogs c'est énorme moi je vois
rien c'est une malheureuse banquiers qui
est un moment fser alors qu'on a un
petit peu à gauche et on va contourner
la plaque
et là tu crois qu'elle y est loin devant
l'os maintenant je suis plus le même
moi je la vois sérieusement je vois de
la mer libre à mon avis deux fois avec
ça parce que c'est tellement envie
désormais la voiture c'est bien mais
quiconque hôtel quand tu as une grande
plaque
qu'est ce que tu veux faire et tu peux
pas s'il va pas rentrer non666 les faits
mais non 500 mètres de long la plaque et
tu vois sur la casse
pour la première fois notre progression
est stoppée la meilleure solution dans
une telle situation et d'attendre que
les courants et les vents favorables
disperse les glaces les autorités de
moments ce que sont inquiètes elles nous
demandent ainsi qu'aux voilier allemand
qui n'est pas très loin derrière nous
d'attendre la venue du brise glace qui
guide le premier cargo de la saison s'il
ya une compression de la glace il faut
tout faire pour que la grâce appui au
maximum au niveau de la flottaison et
pas trop pas trop haut sur le bouton
parce que c'est l'accord qui est quand
même conçu pour encaisser la compression
ne sont pas les hauts plateaux et
ensuite bon c'est en cas d'écart la
compression nous semble un trop forte
pour bateaux et lens prépare à évacuer
ce bateau rejoindre quelques plaque de
banquise et et attendre de voir ce qui
se passe
[Musique]
le
nous
[Musique]
cherchez une fraude passer l'hiver
notamment parce qu'il faut toi pantalons
collants à ravauder pour l'instant on a
dit tu prenais le parthénon le confort
et la lumière ouais je vais rapporter
ben écoute ça a l'air de se dégager
alors il faut arriver à séparer c'est
par et la brume du nuage de l'eau de la
glace
enfin bon c'est pas évident de voir loin
surtout que la glace ici en sibérie est
vraiment plate pas très fine comme cella
de la banquise de l'année mais ça semble
60 navigables met en route en l'absence
de nouvelles du brise glace qui doit se
trouver encore loin derrière nous et
malgré les recommandations de mourmansk
nous décidons de reprendre notre
progression
te falloir faire un gauche droite qui
lie tout de suite à gauche
20 50 m
[Musique]
moi
la coque de vagabond est construite sur
le même principe qu'un brise-glace son
fond plat et surélevée permet de monter
sur les plaque de banquise
c'est le poids du bateau qui casse la
glace et permet de se frayer un chemin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trois jours seulement après notre départ
de dixon le cap qui new skin besoin de
ses portes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hormis les quelques navires qui passent
durant le cours était seuls les
hélicoptères peuvent y accéder
l'hiver les températures extrêmes et la
nuit polaire font de ce cap un des
endroits habités les plus inhospitaliers
de la planète
aujourd'hui seule une vingtaine de
militaires et quelques scientifiques qui
vivent bien souvent considéré comme la
clé du passage du nord-est ce cap est le
plus septentrional de l'asie est bien
souvent le dernier à dégeler incroyable
incroyable
ils ont mis quelques morceaux pour
décorer mais c'est nous avait recommandé
d'attendre les convois il est passé
quelques heures après nous le dag marle
les allemands sont arrivés quelques
heures après nous aussi donc ça s'est un
jour assez fort pour nous bien sûr parce
que ça qu'on précise à une super
progression d'une bonne progression de
l'exposition les allemands qui partent
l'année dernière c'est détroit n'a pas
dégelé du tous s'étaient même pas
envisageable de passer alors ce qui est
devant nous on se demande dans la quelle
vitesse on va le faire presse mais je
commence à plus douter j'ai vraiment le
sentiment qu'on sera à providencia mois
septembre au plus tard
[Musique]
allons-nous bénéficier d'une année
exceptionnelle qui nous permettrait
d'atteindre meriem au cours de l'été
nous aimerions le croire mais nous
entamons à peine la deuxième moitié du
trajet et il est impossible d'anticiper
un fort courant peut transformer une eau
libre banquise et bloquer toute
progression
[Musique]
trois jours après avoir passé le cap
chez lui au skins nous rencontrons à
nouveau de fortes concentrations de
glace devant nous des morceaux de
banquise disloqué s'étendent à l'infini
il va falloir étudier de très près la
route à prendre afin de ne pas rester
bloqué dans ce labyrinthe
gérard monte dans le mât ces indications
permettront la france qui est à la barre
d'éviter ces véritables pièges de glace
maurice et eric dorment dans quelques
heures si la situation n'a pas évolué ce
sera leur tour de se battre avec des
morceaux de banquise est ce que c'est
par amour jusqu'au bout de l'horizon
y'a pas de bouchon
est-ce que tu parles micro la regarder
ok
bush à la gauche la droite va bien
mais est ce qu'on m'a donné ma blessure
marc raynaud libre
[Musique]
plutôt tout à fait contre le grand ou un
tout petit peu plus à gauche c'est mieux
un mois mais tout droit exactement à
exactement à gauche du grand quoi
[Musique]
je peux la gauche hors jeu mais si non
ce que je vois je vais essayer de
pousser quand même
lalas exploite là c'est une grosse
claque ouais mais tu vois je te laisse
pour l'instant il faut juste un coup
perche là je vais le donner moi le
perche il faut non mais et c'est un peu
con
[Musique]
dormir quand ça cogne l'équipage fatigue
la navigation demande beaucoup de
concentration
la présence d'une deuxième personne
pendant les quarts de veille devient
indispensable
chacun ne dispose plus que de deux
heures de sommeil toutes les quatre
heures
après plusieurs heures de slalom au
milieu des glaces un chenal s'ouvre
devant nous vers le sud on change de cap
et évitons ainsi de prolonger un combat
à l'issue incertaine
c'est avec soulagement que nous
retrouvons les eaux libres de la mer des
laptev
atteint c'est amusant parce que on est
dans des petits font mes petits feront
là je vois quatre mètres en 28
bon alors il ya les vagues aussi un et
c'est curieux parce que
on va toujours à peine la terre et voilà
les quatre mètres de fond là mais en
plus pas mal hein et à savoir on avait
du courant avec nous on marche à 7
noeuds je crois aussi qu'on a sommé nos
cousins germains dagmar parce que
définitivement personne ne les a vus
entre ici et ici
mais nous votre situation points
on applique à surville font là quand
même
cinq jours après notre départ du cap
chelios keane
nous arrivons indique si notre troisième
et dernière escale autorisée avant le
détroit de béring vagabond est un des
premiers voiliers étranger à être
autorisé à naviguer le long de cette
route depuis la chute de l'union
soviétique
chaque escale donne lieu à
d'interminables palabres de la part des
garde-côtes
peu habitués aux procédures à appliquer
dans pareil cas on risque notre
interprète est l'hôte de glace connaît
les méandres de l'administration russe
et s'avère efficace
tiksi comme dixon est un des ports
principaux de la route du nord
la ville a vu son activité chuter et sa
population diminuer d'année en année en
1999 alors qu'il tentait de franchir le
passage du nord-est en un seul été le
voilier russe apostol andré ne plus
progresser davantage et passa liberati
xi capitale de la province de yakoutie
tiksi abrite une population d'evenk de
russes et de yacks août après la chute
de l'union soviétique la crise
économique russe certaines des minorités
ethniques de sibérie ont sombré dans le
désoeuvrement et la misère
d'autres au contraire se sont efforcés
de retrouver leur mode de vie
traditionnel afin de survivre à tous ces
bouleversements
[Musique]
le
nous
mais
ad nous
[Musique]
nos points de ravitaillement sont rares
et nous ne sommes toujours pas à l'abri
d'un hivernage dans les glaces pendant
que france essaye de dénicher quelques
légumes frais boris entreprend de
marchander du poisson à deux pêcheurs
évêques la transaction les aura pas
coûté grand chose mais ce petit apport
inattendu sera précieux pour nous amis
pêcheurs
gérard vérifie la qualité du gasoil
avant de faire le dernier plein de
l'expédition
les 4500 litres de carburant nous
serviront encore d'hivernage à alimenter
un système de chauffage central
si nous devons passer l'hiver sur
vagabond il nous faudra chauffer en
permanence car en sibérie la température
avoisine régulièrement les moins 40
degrés
[Applaudissements]
et
après trois semaines de navigation
depuis moment sq nous entamons le
dernier tiers du trajet berry nous
semble à portée de rêve
nous ne devons pas oublier pour autant
que certains de nos prédécesseurs ont
été bloqués à quelques jours seulement
du détroit de béring
la critique si ça va bien on avance bien
sauf que c'est le brouillard quoi elle
vous pouvez yard total la température
s'est blessé un peu
nuit commence à revenir ça s'est un peu
moins de rue par exemple à savoir pour
l'instant on n'a pas de glace mais quand
il va y avoir de la glace
ça risque d'être chaud contre un tyran
l'ami nuit et brouillard glace ça fait
beaucoup de choses
moment si nous conseillaient de ne pas
traîner ne pas tarder à tichy parce
qu'un banc de glace a eu tendance à
dériver vers la zone où on arrive
maintenant pour l'instant en tout cas
pas de
pas de pas de confirmation ni de
mourmansk ni de visu ni d'ailleurs sur
ces glaces
s
oh non non c'est plutôt le plus tôt la
chaîne
servez vous dirais que les liens étaient
sur la table y en a qui surveillent la
route comme on sait jamais mais je
métropole et encore
si on trouve pas de miyazaki un peu
comme relais de lassouts
et là il ya la lucky et tombe peut-être
un peu vite parce que
version plutôt là et donc
parce que ça me ce grand voile qui est
un peu pété il faudrait réussir à
affaler attention
yes la nuit tombe
là où se lève et notre grand voile ne
semble plus impossible de la fal et par
vent trop violent
il nous faudra donc être vigilant et
prier pour qu'il n'y ait pas trop de
glace sur notre chemin
raté
protéger la fin des douanes on attache
la dame en attachement sinon tu reçois
revol
pendant que gérard manoeuvre
difficilement la grand voile
eric décès en vain de contacter le
dagmara m voilà une semaine que nous
n'avons pas eu de nouvelles du voilier
allemand et nous aimerions savoir s'en
sont devant mais derrière nous
gbagbo demande allemande demander si ce
vagabond des demandes allemandes dagmar
on vagabonde
le jour permanent de l'été arctique
laisse place à deux courtes nuits qui
rendent la navigation nocturne de plus
en plus risqué
[Musique]
vagabond arrivants merde et choc c'est
ici qu'en 1879 la jeanne est commandée
par george washington de long se trouve
a bloqué dans les glaces
puis dériva pendant deux ans avant de
couler au large de l'archipel de
nouvelle sibérie depuis le détroit porte
son nom
oui
[Musique]
la nuit fut agité le vent la houle et
l'obscurité ont perturbé notre
navigation au milieu des morceaux de
banquise
une fois de plus nous avons dû doubler
l'écart de veille et réduire nos temps
de sommeil
une petite tache blanche à la surface
attire l'attention de gérard en nous
approchant nous découvrons un ours
polaire
nous sommes surpris de l'observer en
pleine mer aussi loin des côtes
le plus gros prédateur de l'arctique n'a
pas peur de l'homme et n'hésite pas à
attaquer il chasse les morses les
bélougas et les baleines capable de
survivre aux climats extrêmes
il peut rester jusqu'à deux minutes en
apnée sous l'eau et nager jusqu'à 100 km
il
après seulement 28 jours de navigation
depuis mourmansk
nous voici déjà proche du détroit de
béring jamais nous n'aurions espérer une
progression aussi rapide
si les glaces ne s'y opposent pas nous
atteindrons notre but dans quelques
jours la rapidité de notre progression
et le peu d'escale autorisé non pas
étancher notre soif de découverte
nous improvisons alors quelques escales
sauvage
ici un navire canadien échoué nous
rappelle que les conditions de
navigation n'ont pas toujours été aussi
clémente
c'est non loin de là dans une petite
baie que le suédois noren skol d'abord
de la vega se retrouvent a pris par les
glaces
le 30 septembre 1878 à un jour seulement
du détroit de béring après un hivernage
dans des conditions extrêmes
il fut le premier à réussir le passage
du nord-est
loire réussir en un seul était sur un
petit voilier de 15 mètres est un défi
des temps modernes
mais rendons hommage aux aventuriers du
grand nord qui il y à 150 ans avait déjà
foulé ses terres
et presque réussi le passage en insolite
et sans les moyens dont disposent
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
vous aimez regarder les clubs le vent
température de l'air
3 3 ces cumuls et une version
en passant non loin des côtes nous
repérons un petit village
la tentation est forte de nous y arrêter
maurice s'inquiète de cette escale
imprévue il se sent responsable
vis-à-vis de l'administration qui nous
autorise à naviguer ici
police
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
des invités
le capitaine yann délégation permis
bateau de pacha remplissent pas de
poisson
avant même d'avoir mis pied à terre des
villageois
poussés par la curiosité qui est nous
rendre visite les échanges avec des
étrangers sont noirs les questions sont
nombreuses
situés en sibérie orientale dans la
province de tchoukotka le village de
niche qui abrite six ans habitant pour
la plupart de l'élite shoot leach look
après avoir longtemps résisté aux armes
et kozak furent les derniers autochtone
de sibérie à se soumettre à la loi russe
aujourd'hui au nombre de quinze mille
ils pratiquent l'élevage de rennes la
chasse aux morts c'est aux mammifères
marins
nous reprenons la mer les conditions de
navigation sont idéales berry n'est plus
très loin
là on est juste aux portes de béring
c'est un moment fort pour moi c'est
parce qu'elle erin c'est le cadre de
l'article
pèse lourd sur
difficile d'accès quoi
moi je suis pas un grand fan de quatre
ans
les merdias lanta
j'aurai dans les eaux tranquilles
en entrée en sciant du mans mais
voici ces gars je suis très content
voici quatre semaines que nous naviguons
dans l'océan glacial arctique
après avoir traversé cinq mères
différentes
nous voici aux portes du pacifique à
quelques kilomètres seulement de la sq
c'est déjà sur le caf
ouais
avoir un crédit
yes she rue gaucho donc non il masque
enfin
[Musique]
une fois qu'on sera là qu'on aurait
acheté lors tranquillement on pourra
gérer la grand voile je pense qu'on voit
c'est mieux comme ça
nous sommes à une heure seulement du
détroit de béring son passage
symbolisera la réussite de l'expédition
mais le vent est trop fort pour
continuer à naviguer et nous nous
abritons près du village de walem
l'enrouleur n'a pas pu être réparé alors
nous appelons la grand voile pour ne pas
nous faire surprendre par le mauvais
temps le vent tourner et rend favorable
notre progression vers béring mais là où
il se lève et il devient trop dangereux
de rester au mouillage vagabond pourrait
dériver contre la falaise
c'est bien parce que ces dynamiques
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas sûr qu'on puisse attendre
nous avons appris par radio que le
dagmara n est loin derrière nous le
pensions passer le détroit de béring
ensemble mais latente au mouillage
s'avère plus dangereuse que la
navigation
nous passons donc le détroit de béring
sais plus
[Musique]
preston timidria sa combativité
s'installe au mondial en choeur c'est
dire que péta du caribou pour arrondir
[Musique]
la fin du nord-est réussir le passage du
nord-est en voilier et en un seul été
est une première dans l'histoire de la
navigation colère aujourd'hui après midi
fyk eric france et gérard préparent leur
retour en bretagne entre tous les
chemins qui mènent ils choisiraient une
folie pure celui des morts mais cette
fois ils longeront les eaux canadiennes
pour boucler le tour de l'arctique
morgane ribout ce chiffre at ça irait
vite sharon au stade bernabéu jiabao
gignac dans ses divers entre l'esa à
jean perrin cheville et je m'appuie ou
de rêver sauf qu'au tibet a pas souri
benoît y avait beaucoup d'autres et les
chiens chamayou ya six d entre eux
copiez pas de course qu'android tandis
qu'eric abidal
[Musique]
jeanine capitale tels kassaman comme
serrra ce cadre-là yabi doriot ça vaille
est aussi que nous avons estimé paris
travail en bus ou en ssii ou frappe ça
irait vite sharon au stade hassan abou
dayyah pausini abdou ses divers pans de
l'esa à jim par un giga espagne